Thomas Jefferson is canceled he's
cancelled it was only a matter of time
but the man who wrote the Declaration of
Independence one of the fathers of our
country he's cancelled a statue of
Thomas Jefferson that was erected
outside of Thomas Jefferson High School
was toppled in North Portland Oregon it
was then spray-painted one of the bits
of spray-paint said slave-owner there
are lots of signs and insulting things
written all around it rioters knocked
down two more statues on the very same
night and I'm trying to remember I'm
thinking back to way way back like maybe
two years ago if somebody could have
predicted this was a slave owner was
George Washington a slave owner so will
George Washington now lose his status
are we gonna take down excuse me are we
going to take down are we gonna take
down statues - George why how about
Thomas Jefferson what do you think of
Thomas Jefferson you like him
okay good are we gonna take down the
statue because he was a major slave
owner now we gonna take down his statue
so you know what it's fine you're
changing history you're changing culture
he's right you're changing history
you're changing culture and no one
including many many conservatives is
willing to do a damn thing about it and
I have a hunch why I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
welcome back not just Thomas Jefferson
who got knocked down basically anybody
who was involved in any way in the
creation of this country is getting
knocked down and even some conservatives
are kind of okay with this I'm not
saying they're calling for the statues
to come down but they're kind of okay
with this they're playing into the
left-wing premises I have a hunch why
and I think the problem actually runs a
lot deeper than anybody's talking about
I think most of our modern political
problems all tie in to the same central
issue which we will get to in one second
first I got to answer though the
question from yesterday you know I asked
yesterday how long Chaz will last the
Capitol Hill autonomous zone run by
anarchists in Seattle they were now
renamed it to chop and I felt the best
answer was from Danny who on YouTube
said Chaz will live forever in
communists hearts and that's kind of the
point isn't it I don't think Chaz will
live very long in reality although
frankly I think the mayor of Seattle is
kind of okay with it but I only going to
live that long in the physical world but
these communist utopias they live
forever in the communists hearts
Christian's go to heaven socialists go
to communists I would ask you what the
in the comments section right now what
shop should change their name to next
because chop isn't going to last right
chop is obviously it was Chaz now it's
chop what is the next stage of that let
me know let me know is the statues keep
tumbling down Jefferson goes down to
other statues go down in Portland a
couple nights ago Columbus Christopher
Columbus you know they've been tearing
down statues beheading statues
vandalizing statues of Columbus for
years now a Columbus statue is
officially coming down this is according
not just to the rioters but to the
school administration at Columbus State
Community College in Columbus Ohio I
don't know if they thought through this
all the way if they're gonna give in to
the premise here that Columbus is a
really bad terrible racist bigot
terrible guy that they're gonna take the
statue down they're probably gonna have
to rename the school right well if they
renamed the school they're probably have
to rename the town right you can't
you can't live in this racist town named
after a racist person if they're gonna
rename the town they're probably enough
to read in the country right Columbia
you know like Pablo Escobar Colombia
they're named after Christopher Columbus
why aren't there popular uprisings in
Colombia we have to rename the country
because of the terrible history of this
terrible terrible man this this
according to the president of Columbus
State Community College the removal of
the Christopher Columbus statue is a
symbolic gesture of our commitment to
our College and in our community to
continue and accelerate the fight
against systemic racism recent events
including the senseless deaths of
African Americans and the resulting
anguish across the nation compelled us
to act on a years-long
internal dialogue about the statue and
the message it sends to our community
the message namely that it's made that
the place is named after Christopher
Columbus anthem is pretty simple message
right this inflection point will inform
college policy and action both now and
for years to come it will you're right
it will inform college policy and
probably town policy and property state
policy and probably national policy as
well the most dispiriting part of this
for me but I think also the most
illuminating is that it's not just these
liberals running colleges it's not just
the far-left rioters running Chaz and
chop and every riot around the country
even some conservatives are buying into
this bogus premise we'll get to that in
one second first I got to thank our
friends over at movement you are
probably spending a lot of time staring
at your screen right now that's what
we've all been doing for many months
really it's what we've all been doing
for many years you got to protect your
eyes okay we're living in crazy times
right now we've made some pretty
significant lifestyle adjustments we're
spending more time than ever on digital
screens that's why the team over at
movement wants to make sure that you're
taking care of your eyes with their ever
scroll blue light filtering glasses
crafted with special blue light lenses
movement ever scroll glasses protect
your eyes from digital eye strain and
other harmful effects from blue light
like headaches and poor sleep I didn't
buy this at first I thought blue light
whether this sounds like some fake thing
that people are just invent inventing
new problems then I filtered out the
blue light
I felt much better okay it just puts
less strain on your eyes and the great
thing about movement is when you do that
you look really good movement is just so
good at style I go get these I'm telling
you you are not going to regret it you
can get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to movement
MVM t-dot-com slash Knowles I now don't
use a screen without filtering out the
blue light that's how good it is
get the ever scroll solution better
sleep better focus better style
MVM t-dot-com slash Knowles Canada wles
and join the movement really dispiriting
here
that pretty much everybody is going in
on the statue toppling most
conservatives are not saying we actually
need to pull down the statues where we
actually need to rename things but what
some conservatives are doing is granting
the left's premise that these people
Thomas Jefferson Christopher Columbus
actually were terrible rotten people and
that the reality is it's just not true
so there's a writer at the Washington
Examiner tiannan Lowe who you know I
like watching her when she goes on cable
news I have nothing against her
personally I don't I don't mean to
attack her but she published a very bad
take very incorrect take which is titled
Christopher Columbus was pretty evil by
the standards of his own time we've
heard this I've read versions of this
article many many times specifically
since 2006 that's when it's become
especially popular and the story runs
something like this we think Christopher
Columbus is a good guy but actually
there are accounts that came out that
say he was a monster he was the tyrant
of the West Indies he was evil by the
standards even of his own day and
everyone around him thought that he was
a no-good terrible rotten person and not
true all of those accounts rely on one
defamatory letter written by Francisco
de Bobadilla Columbus's chief political
rival in the new world to rely on this
guy's account to give us the whole
picture of Columbus's life would be like
relying on Hillary Clinton's biography
of Donald Trump to tell us everything
about Donald Trump maybe there's a thing
or two that's true in there but
bias is so overwhelming the conflict of
interest is so overwhelming that it's
not a reliable source and they every one
of these attacks on Columbus uses this
one guy who had it out to get him in
Columbus by the way was so offended by
the account that Bobadilla wrote of him
that he actually turned down money from
the crown to to fight against this
defamatory stuff okay he spent he spent
every moment practically until his dying
day after this was written trying to get
this written out of his his record
because he felt it was so untrue so
defamatory and the crown by the way the
Spanish crown that set Columbus on the
voyage and then picked povedilla to
replace him the Spanish crown had a lot
of interest in believing bobba diaz
account because then it could withhold
the full amount of money that they owed
Christopher Columbus there was a lot of
politics involved the reality is
Christopher Columbus is one of the
greatest men who ever walked the earth
okay even on this issue of how he
treated the natives compared to the
Spaniards who he traveled with Columbus
was relatively a pretty good guy who
weighed in on their behalf who adopted
the son of one of his Native American
friends who even Bartolome de las casas
the first resident bishop of the
Americas one of the great defenders of
Native Americans for the first great
defender of Native Americans wrote of
Columbus but he was a good guy he was an
admirer of Christopher Columbus until
the end of his life on top of that he
was the greatest navigator of his age he
was more or less self-taught he was of
relatively low birth he married well you
know he moved up he was relentless he
traveled all over the place he lobbied
Portugal to send him on this quest
around the world did that to the Indies
he lobbied Spain to do it he read books
and books and books worked every angle
of the system and he made it to the new
world using nothing but dead reckoning
okay he didn't even have the most basic
equipment that as he was traveling he
was dead reckoning and discovered this
world that we now get to enjoy and from
which we get to spit on Columbus's
memory it's just unfortunate not to put
too fine a point on to it why are we
doing
this why are even conservatives buying
some of these premises
maybe we shouldn't tear the statue down
but Columbus was a pretty bad guy I
wasn't great you know Thomas Jefferson
he was a pretty bad guy I robert e lee
that guy especially Robert Ely I mean he
was a southerner he fought for the
Confederacy
dagnabbit that's the only thing they
ever say about him why are some
conservatives willing to do this some
people still don't get it some people
think that this is just about only the
left or only the right and they're
totally different and totally different
perspectives they think this is we only
have economic problems they're totally
different from cultural problems they're
completely separate they think that one
odd feature of our culture today is
we're not replacing ourselves no one's
having any kids anymore so our birth
rate is below replacement they think
that problem is totally disconnected to
the fact that our nursing homes are
overrun and just got wrecked by
coronavirus specifically in New York
that story came out with Andrew Cuomo
packing up the nursing homes that they
think these are totally disconnected
that that we're not replacing ourselves
we're not having any kids and we don't
know what to do with our old people with
our parents and our grandparents seems
to me they're not completely separate
problems any of these things seems to me
all of these issues derive from the same
central pathology of modernity
selfishness I think it's simple I think
it's actually a simple answer you don't
need some highfalutin political jargon
here I think it comes down to
selfishness okay and you know that we're
a bit of a selfish culture now we spend
an entire month celebrating pride pride
the definition of selfishness right and
self self obsession I think there's a a
real connection here a culture that does
not value its inheritance whether it's a
financial you know money inheritance or
whether it's a cultural inheritance is
going to squander that and it's not
gonna pass anything along to its
posterity except for debt right it's oh
this is a weird thing we live in a
culture now that does not leave an
inheritance to the to the future
generations
it leaves debt
likewise a generation that's not
interested in the future not interested
in posterity not interested in having
kids or leaving them anything has no
reason at all to pass on their their
cultural inheritance or their financial
inheritance or anything who cares about
the history of America who cares about
Thomas Jefferson who cares about any of
our traditions we don't even care about
the future we don't care about who comes
after us the fact that we're forgetting
about our past ties into the fact that
we're forgetting about our future and
vice versa and what you have I'm
remembered of this line from George
Orwell in 1984 the line goes every
record has been destroyed or falsified
every book rewritten every picture has
been repainted every statue and street
building has been renamed every date has
been altered and the process is
continuing day by day and minute by
minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except an endless present in which the
party is always right
that's George Orwell describing this
this sort of dystopian hellscape in 1984
and that description I think suits
progressives pretty well progressives
hate the past it's right there in their
name they want to progress beyond the
past the progressives always want to
topple those statues down and maybe even
the sadder part is it basically suits
conservatives well as well because
conservatives at least in recent years
have only been focused on the present
they haven't been focused on conserving
very much of anything you saw this at
the Supreme Court just this week but
you've seen this in in recent decades
we've we've lost on so many issues we've
given up so many things and then there's
this irony which is that conservatives
always talk about fiscal responsibility
yet when we get into the government we
spend just as much money if not more as
the left because we're trying to paper
over cultural problems by just spending
spending our way out of it by just
having this facade of prosperity we
don't care if the left topples all the
statues and ruins our whole culture so
long as we get a few tax cuts every once
in a while yeah and not permanent ones
but you know just every so often give us
a tax cut and then that's fun well that
doesn't conserve much of anything at all
and I think it just comes down to this
myopic focus on the present
not the past not the future not the
people who came before us not the people
who come after it's just us ourselves
just this kind of selfishness we can
serve nothing I made this point just a
few days ago if you are not able to
conserve anything that there's no point
in being conservative right now right
there in the word if you're not doing
the thing the word says then what's the
purpose and I said this specifically
with regard to the conservative legal
movement call it originalism call it
textualism I guess call it what at the
Federalist Society I don't know we've
gotten a lot of conservative judges and
yet we haven't gotten a lot of
conservative decisions we've kept
Obamacare we have an overturn Roe vs.
way we've radically redefined marriage
according to modern ideas from the bench
now we've redefined sex to mean whatever
I want to think that I am we've
redefined sex to be modern gender in the
ideology we haven't conserved much at
all senator Josh Hawley who I think is
one of the senators kind of waking up to
these ideas he gave an absolute barn
burner speech on the Senate floor
yesterday addressing this precise point
this decision this Bostock case and the
majority who wrote it it represents the
end of something it represents the end
of the conservative legal movement or
the conservative legal project as we
know it after Bostock that effort as we
know it as it has existed up to now it's
over and I say this because if
textualism and originalism give you this
decision if you can invoke textualism
and originalism in order to reach a
decision an outcome that fundamentally
changes the scope and meaning and
application of statutory law then
textualism and originalism and all of
those phrases don't mean much at all
so Hawley is part of a trend that you're
seeing not just in the Senate but among
conservatives broadly to actually fight
back a little bit to actually try to
conserve some things to not just focus
on the
occasional tax cut and let the left take
over the whole culture and I think it's
about damn time that people started
thinking that way we'll get to that in
one second we'll get to how he's doing
it first though got to think our friends
over at Bambi having a good HR
department is the key to running a great
company you know this way your eye view
if you've ever forget run a business if
your work for a business you know HR
issues can kill a business wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations the
regulations are changing by the minute
these days it seems and HR manager
salaries are not cheap you know much HR
managers get on average 70 grand a year
nice work if you can get it Bambi
spelled B am B EE was created
specifically for small businesses you're
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email or read real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business they
help you manage your employees day to
day how much do you pay them $99 a month
it's an unbelievable deal month-to-month
no hidden fees cancel anytime
you did not start your business I assure
you because you wanted to spend time on
HR compliance so right now go to Bambi
calm slash Michael to schedule your free
HR audit that is Bambi calm slash
Michael BAM to the be EE calm slash
Michael mi CH AE L head over there right
now or if not right now if not right to
second then right after the show answer
Josh Holly is one of the people pushing
back finally in the conservative legal
movement
I guess what's the movement I don't know
the movements changing right now the old
consensus was don't ever use the
government when the left attacks you
when the left attacks you don't use the
government because if you use the
government now to fight an actual attack
from the left then maybe some day
hypothetically the left will use that
same government mechanism that it's
already using against you understand the
illogic here but I still hear this I
hear this from friends of mine they'll
say Michael conservatives can't use the
few levers of power that we have to
fight back again
for example big tech censorship right
now because if we empower the government
to fight back against censorship in this
way that the left is foisting on us
right this very minute then the left
someday hypothetically might censor us
right I don't need to think about that
hypothetically I don't need to imagine
that it's already happening they're
already doing it the question is not
whether we're gonna set ourselves up in
this terrible position for the left to
censor us that's already a given the
question is are we going to fight back
yes or no Hawley and others are saying
it doesn't make sense to worry about
this future hypothetical problem and
because of that future I figured out the
hypothetical problem ignore the current
one that is attacking us and I think
censorship is the best example here we
saw a huge story on this yesterday NBC
News News I put news in quotes because
NBC News is not a news organization and
they've more or less 10-minute there
they're a leftist activist organization
and they lobbied Google to kick off a
conservative investigative outlet so NBC
News tried to get the Federalists maybe
you I read the Federalists maybe you
read the Federalists they do great
journalistic work they were really good
on the Obama gate scandal they've been
really good on some of the corruption
that's going on in the government they
tried to get them kicked off of Google's
advertising platform and what that means
by the way Google has I think the
largest advertising platform in the
world what that means is it's not like
you're totally banning the Federalists
from the internet but you're cutting off
more or less anyway it could make money
and so if it can't make money obviously
the company is gonna wither and die this
is what NBC writes Google's ban of the
websites which would be the Federalists
and another web site Zero Hedge comes
after the company was notified of
research conducted by the Center for
countering digital hate British
nonprofit the combats online hate and
misinformation
they found that ten us-based websites
have published what they say are racist
articles about the protests pause right
there the federalists is not a racist
website if the federalists is a racist
website then the word racism truly has
no meaning what they mean by racist is
contradicting the leftist
narrative what they mean by racist is in
anyway disagreeing with leftists at an
NBC News they call it racist and they
smear it baselessly they found that ten
us-based websites have published but
they say racist articles about the
protests you know the riots and
projected that the websites would make
millions of dollars through Google ads
Google blocked the federalists from its
advertising platform after the NBC News
verification unit brought the project to
its attention Zero Hedge had already
been demonetised prior to NBC News's
inquiry Google said Google came out
yesterday after a big hubbub the
federalists was trending all day on
Twitter and they said oh no the
federalists wasn't wasn't demonetized a
big misunderstanding don't worry it was
an issue with the comment section but
don't worry we got rid of that it's a
trial balloon that's what they always do
the fake news truly fake news at NBC
News made a political operative attack
on a competitor and a conservative the
Federalists Google obliged and
demonetised it and more or less said
they were going to destroy the business
then there was enough of an outcry that
NBC backed off and Google backed off as
well and said oh no is a big
misunderstanding meanwhile by the way
the other website Zero Hedge do you
monetize because no one made a big
hubbub about that this is going to
increase throughout the election we are
still five months away the old consensus
would have said well you know if if you
don't like what Google is doing just
make another Google yeah sure they have
a monopoly over the flow of information
around the internet but ah well that's
too bad nothing we can do my hands are
tied let the left destroy the culture or
let's just hope for another tax cut at
some point please we got to get those
judges look we'll get the judges in and
the judges will stab us in the back but
hey it's okay cuz I guess we'll get
another tax cut or something right yeah
that's not a good way to conduct
politics that's the old consensus I
think the new idea says hold google to
account by whatever means are available
to us section 230 right the section 230
is part of the Communications Decency
Act that is one way the Conservatives
might be able to go after big tech Oleg
arcs for abusing their powers and
violating the law break them up as a
monopoly just break just do it why not
why wouldn't
we they are now trying to tip elections
for the left
they are barring conservatives from
doing business anywhere even go after
them gotta grow a spine folks gotta grow
some cojones if you want to have an
effective political movement speaking of
these sorts of questions just to see
what we're up against from the other
side of the Senate aisle Tim Kaine u.s.
senator the man who was almost one
heartbeat away from becoming the second
woman president Tim Kaine gave a speech
yesterday on the Senate floor in which
he blamed America for inventing slavery
and the only problem with Tim Kaine
speech is that it was completely untrue
we need to do much more within the
criminal justice system but also within
all of our systems to dismantle the
structures of racism that our federal
state and local governments carefully
erected and maintained over centuries we
know a little bit about this in Virginia
the first African Americans in into the
English colonies came to Point Comfort
Virginia in 1619 they were slaves
they've been captured against their will
but they landed in colonies that didn't
have slavery there were no laws about
slavery in the colonies at that time the
United States didn't inherit slavery
from anybody we created it I think maybe
Tim Kaine should check up on his history
actually in the Declaration of
Independence written by that guy who got
cancelled Thomas Jefferson Jefferson
complains about how the incipient United
States inherited slavery from the
British and complained about that as an
institution that was that has had a
negative impact on the country where
does Tim Kaine think the slaves came
from when they landed in Virginia the
slaves came from Africa and they were
bought from an African slave traders
people who still practice slavery to
this day slavery still practiced in the
Middle East to this day slavery still
practiced in East Asia to this very day
as a matter of fact not only did the
United States not invent slavery because
slavery goes back not just to those
slave traders in the centuries before
the
States came to be goes all the way back
to ancient Egypt for instance might be
might behoove mr. Cain to read the Bible
see what the Egyptians did to the Jews
in Egypt goes back throughout all of
human history ironically the West is the
only place that's ever abolished slavery
it's not that we invented slavery we
didn't but we did abolish it and
virtually no one else has that's a good
thing
ironically Tim Cain mentions how slavery
came to Virginia the first officially
declared owner of an arbitrarily
declared slave for life right the
beginning of what we would call our
modern system of slavery in America was
a black man he was a black man from
Angola
now obviously slavery then went on to
become a highly racialized system that
led to racial consequences that went on
for centuries but it shows you that the
situation of how slavery began much more
complicated then mr. Cain would have you
believe a lot of a lot of people believe
this thing if a sitting u.s. senator
believes a lie like this think about how
many people have been taught the very
same lie our goal as conservatives our
job is to push back against those things
and yet unfortunately we keep giving
into left wing premises and
unfortunately I think even some of the
advisors around the president are
beginning to buy into some of those
premises we'll get to that in one second
we'll get to president Trump's big
announcement yesterday we will get to
how the riots actually did cure
coronavirus I called that one too and we
will get to my interview with the White
House chief of staff mark meadows at the
White House I was in Washington last
week got to stop by the White House and
take a minute to sit down with the chief
of staff we'll get a little bit of that
first though got to thank our friends
over it keeps I think I've told you many
times I derive the 80% of my power from
my hair I were to lose my hair things
would not go very well two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left it's a lot easier to
prevent
hair-loss than it is to get that hair
back used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right to your home
prevention is the key keeps treatments
can take up to four to six months or
more to see results so it's important to
act fast the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you will save find
out why keeps has more 5-star reviews
than any of its competitors and nearly a
hundred thousand men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention medication
starts at just ten bucks a month if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps calm slash Knowles
to receive your first month of treatment
for free my gift to you so that you too
can can keep eighty percent of your
power ke EPS calm / Knowles
so president yesterday maybe big
announcement the announcement was on
police reform and I get it I get the
political calculation here but I think
the president is getting bad advice from
his advisors we'll get to that in just
one second first though got to thank you
thank you so much for subscribing to the
Michael Nolt Show YouTube channel not
The Daily wire YouTube channel though
I'm you know I'm glad to go over there
give Ben some views but we love that
you're going over to mind and
subscribing we're very close to 70,000
so thank you for that
we've got bonus interviews their
segments breakouts that sort of thing
and recently two brand new interviews
with Maddy Kern's and Jon Burge Maddy
Kern's one of the great journalists in
the country on this issue of gender
ideology and John birch the lead lawyer
on the big Supreme Court case that has
enshrined gender ideology into law go
check that out
by the way we got a backstage coming
tomorrow and we can tell you some
serious facts folks amid the crazy lies
of the mainstream media
you gotta get the readers past though
it's three bucks a month it's you know
not not too much money I think you could
you could probably part with three bucks
a month but I'll make it even better for
you
you can save two-thirds on your first
month just 99 cents so go get it break
the lives of the mainstream media daily
wire.com slash subscribe we'll be right
back with a lot more
President Trump announced yesterday a
big police reform plan in the Rose
Garden the plan is receiving mixed
reviews I will tell you the good the bad
and the ugly here's the president thank
you all for being here as we take
historic action to deliver a future of
safety and security for Americans of
every race religion color and Creed
we're joined today by law enforcement
professionals and community leaders
though we may all come from different
places and different backgrounds were
united by our desire to ensure peace and
dignity and equality for all Americans
okay of course we believe all of this
it's good the President Trump is taking
charge we need strong leadership as the
cities are burning but is this the way
to do it police reform if I had my
druthers if I were advising the
president I would have President Trump
release an executive order on criminal
justice reform that puts more of these
criminals burning the cities down into
prison I think that's probably the
better angle I think unfortunately some
of president Trump's advisers are
convincing him to buy into the left-wing
premise that the police are hopelessly
racist and bigoted and slaughtering
innocent black men around the country we
know that isn't happening
okay we have the statistics we went
through them just last week I think on
the show how many unarmed black men were
killed by police last year and by the
way unarmed does not mean not dangerous
unarmed does not mean that the use of
force was not justified but let's even
use that number unarmed how many nine
thousand no nine hundred no 90 no it's
nine every death is a tragedy but nine
is not evidence of systemic police
brutality and racism and yet that's the
premise that the left wants us to buy
into and wants us to buy into that so
that they can get their agenda in there
without really having to sell it to the
American people so I just think the
whole idea of this am i against police
reform no I think powerfully
should constantly be reforming
themselves of course but is that the
message we want to send now I mean what
does the EO do it doesn't do very much
at all it requires new federal
credentials for police departments which
is just another federal regulation being
foisted on states and local governments
and it bans chokeholds in most instances
this is this is the only part of the EEO
with teeth the Attorney General
standards for certification shall
require independent credentialing bodies
to at a minimum confirm that the state
and local law enforcement agencies use
of force policies prohibit the use of
chokeholds except in those situations
where the use of deadly force is allowed
by law so even there if the use of
deadly force is allowed then they can
use a chokehold but are they saying they
can't use a chokehold now in any case
that that seems like you're tying law
enforcement hands behind its back the
problem it's not going to do very much
as an EO I guess the White House thinks
it's going to be good messaging for
people I don't think it's good messaging
though I think we lose ground
I think we lose debates because we give
up premises that the best example of
this would be how we lost the marriage
debate on the right the marriage debate
where are we going to expand the
definition of marriage to include
monogamous same-sex unions the marriage
debate focused on a question what is
marriage for all of human history sexual
difference seem to be at the center of
marriage whether it was polygamous
marriage in certain instances in some
places whether it was monogamous
marriage for most of this tree of the
West is it is the sexual difference have
something to do with that is the the
logical possibility of the creation of
life of something to do with that yeah
the answer to that was always yes and
then a few years ago we decided no that
doesn't have anything to do with it so
that's a debate that's an interesting
debate to have the way the left avoided
that debate which is favorable to the
people who want to maintain a
traditional meaning of marriage is they
just presumed the new definition they
said Oh marriage is a union of two
people who love each other they just
they they redefined it first and then
they said the marriage debate is about
rights do you have the right to get
married but that was never what the
debate was about and nobody
poses equal rights so by the time they
gave a got that premise through the
people who wanted to keep a traditional
definition of marriage already lost the
debate it was already over there was no
debate to be had I think that's what the
left succeeds that maybe more than
anything and that's how they get so much
institutional power if you cede the
premise that the police are racist
terrible bigoted people who are brutal
and they use too much force and they
need to be reined in then it's a lot
easier to get through BLM's radical
leftist premises most of which have
nothing to do with black lives mattering
or civil rights for racial minorities or
anything like that but they get the
premise in and so they get their policy
solutions we lose ground because we give
up the premises you see this not just on
these racial issues you see this on the
virus as well you know how much I hate
to say I told you so I would never do
that
me well sometimes maybe ok and on this
case I will I did a show a week or two
ago that said race riots cure
coronavirus because the mainstream media
and the public health experts and the
politicians told us coronavirus was
SuperDuper deadly if you ever walk
outside your home you're gonna kill
grandma and then all of a sudden there
were all these leftist riots and the
public health officials the very same
one said oh no go out there yeah go out
by the tens of thousands and breathe all
over each other that's fine you're not
going to get coronavirus that'll
actually help stop the spread of
coronavirus but if a few conservatives
want to maintain their civil liberties
that is deadly you can't do that so I
said ok I guess the race riot secured
coronavirus turns out turns out that
might be true or in a way it's true
Minneapolis which had the biggest
uprisings is now reporting over two
weeks later few new positive cases
according to health officials so you
would think after this craziness out
there
two weeks later passed the incubation
period you'd have a spike in cases right
it hasn't happened more than 3,300
protestors have shown up to be tested
for coronavirus 40% of them so about
1300 have gotten their results back
already 1.4 percent tested positive that
is
lower significantly lower then the
positive rate statewide the the
positivity rates statewide is three
point seven percent and among the
rioters peaceful rioters protesters it's
a one point four percent that's also
lower than the current seven-day average
rate of positive tests which similarly
stands at three point seven percent and
this trend isn't just in Minneapolis it
holds up in Chicago Illinois Philly
Pennsylvania Boston throughout
Massachusetts they've they've also seen
very few cases new cases of Cove in
nineteen cropping up so when they tell
you and this is going to be inevitable
that there's gonna be a second wave you
can't go outside if conservatives won't
hold a protest or something the RN C is
going to happen they're gonna say no
you've got to stay indoors forget about
our encouragement of those riots you
have to stay indoors because of
coronavirus just point all that great
science and show that the science at
least the latest science doesn't back
them up speaking of cures president
Trump is being unfairly attacked I know
you'll be shocked to hear that he's
never unfairly attacked is he well yeah
I think he is pretty much every single
day by the mainstream media he's now
being attacked because he spoke a little
loosely he got a little wording wrong
when he was talking about whether or not
we found a vaccine for AIDS but the
attack that the left is making on Trump
I think reveals a lot about their own
hypocrisy they have come up with things
and they've come up with many other
cures and therapeutics over the years
these are the people the best the
smartest the most brilliant anywhere and
they've come up with the AIDS vaccine
they've come up with or the AIDS and as
you know there's various things and now
various companies are involved but the
therapeutic for aids AIDS was a death
sentence and now people live a life with
a pill it's an incredible thing now lots
of people are attacking Trump they say
we don't have a vaccine yet for AIDS
we've got very effective preventive
measures and we've got very effective
treatments and we've got a vaccine in
development but we don't
have officially certified certified
vaccine yet so you're spraying fake news
Trump I can't help but notice though
that this minor gaffe is revealing a big
flaw in the left's argument about
coronavirus because many of the same
people who are mocking Trump right now
for for saying that we have an AIDS
vaccine when we still don't have an AIDS
vaccine even after what 37 years of
research are the very same people
telling us that a corona virus vaccine
is right around the corner what makes
you so confident that we're gonna have
this corona virus vaccine within the
next few months we've been spending 37
years on an AIDS vaccine we don't have
it how many other diseases have gone
around we don't have a vaccine we're
nowhere close to a vaccine it's not as
though when scientists go into the
laboratory they say okay we're gonna
make a vaccine I'm gonna estimate it's
gonna take us about four or five hours
like making a pizza you know it's gonna
that's we know we're gonna get it we
just have to know you're discovering the
vaccine you were developing the vaccine
you don't know what your timetable is
going to be on that so fine you want to
attack Trump form is speaking about the
AIDS vaccine that's okay but then I
think we need to drop what has become
the new left-wing argument which is we
need to shut down our whole country
until we find a cure initially it was
flatten the curve we did successfully
flatten the curve and slowed the rate of
transmission and didn't overwhelm the
hospital system then they transferred
finding flattening the curve to finding
a cure no evidence that we're gonna get
that cure it's one of these gaffes
quote-unquote that Trump makes that I
think actually was pretty advantageous I
think it shows a flaw in their argument
now speaking of the White House I was
hanging around there last week and I sat
down with the White House chief of staff
Mark meadows on my show with Senator Ted
Cruz called verdict this was mr. meadows
his first interview since he became the
chief of staff and I figured there's no
way this guy's going to tell us anything
all right he's got a very private job
arguably the most powerful man in the
world right because he's the chief of
staff at the White House so he is
deciding who gets to come and see the
president what makes
to the President's desk all from behind
the scenes he's gonna be a behind the
scenes guy he's not gonna tell us much
he spilled some tea I got to tell you
mark Meadows really took us behind the
scenes a little bit on some of the
challenges that the administration is
facing specifically when it comes to
leakers and the good news out of that is
the White House is finally beginning to
figure out how to identify those leakers
the other thing that I think that is
critical is you've got this massive
bureaucracy with agencies and you think
well there's a Republican administration
so you but there is the swamp that
continues to go on whether it's a
democrat or republican in in the overall
elected people come and go what Ted was
saying they wait them out and so one of
the great things is is that if Ted or
one of his colleagues they're getting
you know the stiff arm I call it the
legislative Heisman you know if they're
debating that it's real easy for me to
pick up and say you know why am I
getting this phone call from this
senator on you not responding to their
phone call oh well we're busy well I was
busy too and I took his call I mean why
aren't you taking and so sometimes it's
just making them aware that there's
somebody else willing to hold them and
to branch us there I mean this is
actually something it's Senator I know
you've talked a lot about is you've been
talking about for years about social
media censorship censorship of
conservatives well just recently we got
out of out of the executive branch this
executive order on social media
censorship we still don't know a whole
lot about that at least I don't know a
lot about that maybe could you tell us a
little bit about how that came to be
well I think Ted and I know that as
conservatives sometimes our conservative
voice doesn't reach the audience as
quickly or as effectively as it is
normally a diplomatic way to pull yeah
well I can tell you I was one of the few
members of Congress back when I was in
Congress that was actually Shadow banned
by Twitter yeah and so we ought to put
that out on a tweet and see if they take
that down they'll say it wasn't shadow
ban that we were but it only happened to
be for conservative members of Congress
myself Matt Gaetz Devan newness and Jim
Jordan so you're saying he didn't
you didn't make it into that so so one
of the things that it's important is is
that we need to make sure that the Free
Press is really the Free Press yeah and
it's not censored and what what Twitter
has done probably more so than some of
the other social media platforms but
YouTube is doing it as well is they they
come in and they start to actually
monitor content yeah and so it's not
this free open what I call the wild wild
west of social media that's the way I am
and as freedom loving individuals we
want the free market the work but when
the free market starts to get
monopolized by content police then it's
important for us to step in so we did a
neo that actually has the potential of
taking away their their protection from
litigation so if we can't fix it or if
Congress can't face it let the trial
attorneys fix it it'll happen
no clear unleashing the trial attorneys
is a really powerful weapon and I gotta
say this is an issue where a White House
leadership was so needed and it's so
important because we've q and I talked
about this before one of the challenges
on the issue of a big tech censorship is
all the federal agencies are silent and
and it's hard issue where the Antitrust
Division the Department of Justice
doesn't quite fit into what they think
they want to do the FTC it doesn't quite
fit in where do they want to do the FCC
everyone has is sort of looking at their
own slice of the problem and the
president's executive order on this was
important to say dammit this matters I
think it's the biggest threat to
democracy in the whole country but we
needed we needed the president and the
White House to lead to get the rest of
the executive
focused on protecting free speech
altogether right well the interesting
thing and I always try to give you a
little bit of a backstory that no one
else knows so that EEO as it relates to
section 230 we started putting it around
for a little bit of comment on a very
limited basis all of a sudden this
proposed do shows up in the New York
Times and and it really was fed to the
New York Times by a federal worker that
didn't agree with this administration or
at least
peers that they didn't and they didn't
agree with the EO and so they took it
and fed it to outside sources and I'm
glad to say that we were able to track
that person down they no longer work for
the federal government well let me ask a
question here that's a great I hadn't
heard that story and that's that's a
great story
let me take it a slightly different
direction so so the job mark has now I
think is may well be the hardest job in
all of Washington I think that's
probably true and I I love seeing the
surprise on Cruz's face when he hears
about this leaker it's funny you you
just expect everybody's on the same page
in Washington and they all are
constantly talking to each other and I
have found talking to a lot of big
players in Washington that is not the
case there actually is surprised there
are these human interactions really do
matter and I love the way that mark
Meadows says that that individual is no
longer working for the federal
government yep that's a very diplomatic
way to put it a lot lot more great stuff
in that interview so head on over you
can check that at the verdicts podcast
also I'm on Dave Rubens show today I'm
on the Rubin report is my first time
believe it or not going on the Rubin
report even though I've been friends
with Dave for years so head on over
check that out too and then I'll see you
tomorrow I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
borin supervising producers Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling technical
producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen